starts with preparation it starts with
really designing an agenda that is
thoughtful I think you should view every
board meeting like an event like a
retreat like you should know what it is
you're trying to accomplish how you want
people to feel during and after the
meeting what you want as the end result
of every different discussion items the
board chair has to be a facilitator all
great board meetings are interactive in
my opinion it's when directors are
talking amongst themselves about
something and the answer the solutions
are coming out is bigger than greater
than any one individual could have
walked in with so that interactive
nature it takes a good board chair to
facilitate that and make sure everyone's
participating sometimes the board chair
has just got to start at his right and
say I want to hear from every single
person you know on this issue and go
right around the room because it's
really an obligation to participate in
those types of meaningful discussions we
often break up into smaller groups and
allow people to talk before we did that
we found that some people sit and let
others do the work the other thing that
has really helped are our board meetings
become more effective is that I'm doing
a lot less reporting we use what's
called a consent agenda and what that
means is that before the board meeting
happens we send out all the updates that
the committees and I want to do and
people are expected to have read them in
advance and the board itself is a
working board meeting where instead of
asking for updates from everybody and
hearing a lot of talking heads we're
actually asking for advice from the
board and digging deep on issues that
face the organization in my own board
meetings we begin with the discussion
the big issues and we actually conclude
the meeting with the fiduciary and legal
oversight pieces so that the maximum
energy is directed towards
forward-thinking opportunities
challenges and we cover the the
necessary for
in legal but it's not preferenced i also
think that every effective board meeting
is evaluated in some format I'm not
talking about a hundred question you
know survey but rather a simple three by
five card where you ask board members
what's the most important thing that we
talked about what's the least important
thing that we talked about and then
finally I guess after an evaluation I
think a good board chair will summarize
the major conclusions of the meeting and
summarize any actions that the group has
agreed on so that when we walk out of
the room we all know what it is we've
agreed on and what we're going to do now
between now and the next court date it's
really important that board members
enjoy the board experience that they
actually have fun together we actually
build in at my organization Social
Venture Partners international we build
in time for the board members to come in
the night before to have dinner together
where frankly we really don't talk about
work that much and but we build
relationships trust friendships we take
that atmosphere into the room the next
morning and people leave the meeting I
hope feeling more stimulated and
energized than when they arrived in it a
board meeting where people leave feeling
drained and tired is a board meeting
that has failed in its purpose